welcome back to 8 news now some say time
heals all wounds but those who love
stephanie isaacson have dealt with
really horrible pain from her murder for
three decades but a few months ago
everything changed and a generous
donation led to dna identification in
her case sasha loftus joins us in studio
tonight to explain sasha denise and
bryan for more than 30 years stephanie's
family had no idea who killed her now
those who help them find justice want
others to have the same hope
for stephanie isaacson june 1st 1989 was
the day the world stopped turning we'll
start right back
the 14 year old was walking to el dorado
high school when she was sexually
assaulted and murdered
32 years later her case stayed cold but
two months ago her family got the
answers they so desperately searched for
the equivalent of 15 cells was submitted
for this testing dna linked darren
marchand to stephanie's death and it was
all thanks to a generous donation from
justin wu
we were shocked and
you know very happy that we could help
provide some closure to the family the
founder of vegas helps allowed
investigators to send evidence to texas
the family never forgets they they want
to know what happened to their loved one
that's where othram laboratory ceo david
mittelman says marchand was identified
with one-of-a-kind genetic genealogy
testing it gives hope to so many other
cases that may have been designated as
not good enough dna not enough dna while
the process is unique now middleman and
wu hope it can solve countless other
crimes it's a really good feeling to be
able to help a family and bring closure
to those who've waited longer than many
can imagine
darren marchand died by suicide in 1995
records show he was arrested in 1986 as
a suspect in the murder of 24 year old
nanette vandenberg but that case was
dismissed due to a lack of evidence
denise